sometimes i i hear from colleagues like
we've got it all explained and and
nothing is is further from the truth we
don't understand
how from something material an object
like this
something immaterial thoughts
perceptions emotions arise
why are you studying something as fluffy
as meditation
as a neuroscientist it's very good
first question actually i never ever
thought i would be giving a podcast
interview like this one on a subject
that i considered
indeed as fluffy esoteric whatever
definitely not evidence-based uh
remember a journalist uh as a medical
doctor
uh specializing in the study of
consciousness and the damaged brain i
did my phd thesis and
that was in 2000 uh shortly after a
journalist asked me well what do you
think
uh about mindfulness and i remember at
the time
that's the scientist in me checking
quickly well what's being published and
i wasn't convinced
so i i really um
a lot has happened since then
and here i am now as a neurologist
prescribing
meditation in my consultation as a
scientist
studying um what's happening in in the
mind of of uh
these guys who are experts in meditation
also personally i think i
i enjoyed the benefits even if
definitely i'm not a
zen master at all why why
what's drawn you to this interest well
as as is often the case i think and i
also
see it in in the patients i see in the
outpatient clinic
it was a personal crisis so um we
the details are in the book but very
shortly uh
2012 um i
suddenly was uh dead alone with the
three young kids um and
not feeling well uh feeling anxious
about how i would deal with that
feeling also guilty how could this
happen you know
if this little voice in your head
probably sounds familiar and so of
course you can't change the past and
you're worrying about the future and
then other things are uh happening i was
smoking a lot i was drinking the
psychiatrist
prescribed me sleeping pills
antidepressants
and it was it was clear that this wasn't
the inspiring that i wanted to be so i
started doing yoga
but then it was meeting
a buddhist monk in paris where i gave a
tedx
2013 about my area of expertise which is
uh the damaged brain and changes in
consciousness and maturity
translator of the dalai lama talked
about
his area of expertise meditation
compassion and
i still don't know why but very quickly
we we got along well and
he said well obviously i i he felt i i
wasn't
uh well and said
come with me i'm i'm going on this
retreat and
that was the first retweet organized by
mind and life europe
a beautiful german monastery and that
was for me a new world
um and so i said to him well you come to
my lab
in belgium yeah there's a guinea pig and
and so it happened
and and yeah a new area
of research uh started what does the
quote
it is not reality that matters it is the
way you experience reality
mean to you it's
of course it's true right uh
yet the challenge is to to really you
know
um
somehow learn to
um
you need to realize that indeed it's
it's your
mind uh giving you these perceptions
thoughts emotions uh
that's what's really important and and
so
i of course knew that as a
uh neurologist uh seeing all these
families
who lost their loved one and so our
expertise is traumatic brain injury so
from one moment to the other
life is different and and um
so so then you you understand what's
truly important
uh but but to me this is this is
really an important lesson that of
course you
can't change uh everything and it's very
clear also now with kovit you know
there's a couple of things just
happening to us
and then there's things that where we
can of course um
you know have an influence and change
and
work on those things and the rest we
just can
somehow learn to accept them and and for
me that was a
personal um
discovery and and and still working on
that
uh so definitely i think it's it's it's
a powerful
true quotes it seems to have
it's the epicenter of a lot of other
different modes of thinking right so you
have the
dichotomy of control or the stoic fork
from stoicism
uh the sort of cbt as well i suppose
reminds you where the boundaries lie
with regards to what you can and can't
control
then you look at um who wrote man's
search for meaning viktor frankl you
talk about victor frankel man's sort of
final bastion is his ability to respond
however he chooses to in any given
situation
and um yeah realizing that the problem
is not the problem your thoughts about
the problem are the problem
realizing that and fully internalizing
that is a
it's a life-changing moment i think
but one that we we constantly want to
try and resist
for some reason yeah and and maybe also
um so of course you know sometimes i
just see patients where i think
well i don't know what to say because
they they
they lost a child and then i discuss
with them and they say well you know
our other daughter committed suicide and
then
this happened there's so many things
that you say how is this possible okay
so
of course um
it is important and and we need to
acknowledge you know
things that are thrown at us
professionally personally
um but then truly we can we can have an
impact
okay what do i do um with with all of
this and
um somehow uh it's a bit strange
that we need to find it out
uh and it's a trial and error thing
uh why not talk about this
at school i mean um it's so
important it's it's something again i
see in consultation people with anxiety
depression
burnout
and how come we kind of
neglect our emotional well-being how we
can deal with
everything that's happening to us we
have um teachers
uh you know um
working on on our physical well-being
and gymnastics and it's part of the
um curriculum and and to me it's
possible to to have something similar
but but
you know teachers uh who can help us to
deal with our emotional well-being and
so i think meditation
should be taught at school it's a
interesting
thing to think about that
we are thrust into the world as adults
having to deal with the vicissitudes of
life and the inevitable challenges
the death of ourselves and everyone that
we love if that doesn't happen before us
and we are given essentially zero tools
by the formal education system
to be able to deal with that nothing
nothing all of the mindfulness practices
any semblance of rationality that i have
managed to develop
have been completely self-taught or
learned outside of that formal education
system
and i was in full-time education for 18
years
up to a master's level not once did
anyone teach me about
how emotions work about what the nature
of consciousness is about how to look at
the texture of my own mind
about how to separate what is happening
from what i am feeling and so on and so
forth
so yeah i am
the this is a entire other branch to go
down but
i think that there is so much
dissatisfaction with the education
system
wholesale at the moment that it's a
matter of time before that becomes the
majority
and that pressure is going to cause i
know that mindfulness is already being
taught in
in many schools um but even more so than
that talking about time management
skills talking
about to-do list management and
productivity skills general life skills
communication relationship management
sex education that doesn't teach you
things like the vulva
i don't even know what a vulva is but
you know
things that actually matter um so yes
i'm confident for that but today i want
to go through the neuroscience of
meditation you were a man who's had some
of the
the equivalent of the heavyweight world
champions of meditation
in your lab and you've strapped them
into those
strange looking sort of skull cap things
that are behind you on the shelf yeah
for the people that are listening it
looks like what you'd imagine a peasant
from sort of the the middle ages wearing
uh
but that's been thrown into machines so
to start off with
how would you characterize the state of
the brain
in a non-meditator as they just go about
their day
so um somehow this is what
we've been studying for the past 25
years right so so
our expertise is the damaged brain and
and we're
um confronted with people who are
comatose and who survive these very
severe brain damages and then asking the
question well are there any thoughts
or perceptions or emotions
but meditation is really all about that
it's about
the little voice in your head
if i would shut up now and
the people listening would would
experience
these thoughts the continuous stream of
consciousness
jumping from one thing to the other um
and
we start to understand it a little bit
better so with the team
we um identified two networks
of consciousness one is
sensory perceptual awareness that's
everything that you
hear and see right now everything coming
through your senses
would basically depend on a fronto
bridal
um what we call neuronal workspace
and then there's the other component um
internal awareness the little voice in
your head
that permits you to do mental imagery
the brain is a prediction machine it's
very powerful you can anticipate
so that's another network more in the
middle
of the brain front and back also called
the default mode network so important
for these
these thoughts that can of course also
you know
um spin out of control
making you um anxious uh sometimes
uh drive you crazy keep you from uh
having um good sleep so yeah
that's that's what the brain does and
actually we
know it even is the case in the damaged
brain after coma we've seen with these
brain scans there is still
uh some workings of the mind and brain
even in um journal and aesthetics
uh when you're sleeping so you need to
be
brain dead really to have it um
completely silent that's that's the only
way to be brain dead is the only way to
finally escape my thoughts
well i i discussed this with the dalai
lama so thanks to machu rica
my good friend i had the opportunity to
spend
a day and meet a couple of times dalai
lama who's
incredibly inspiring right but
even these these top athletes as you
call them
um you know they have thoughts uh yet
they have learned through tens of
thousands of hours of meditation to
kind of observe them and i think that's
the trick so you just
learn to focus your attention and
meditation to me is about
training your mind it's mental
gymnastics there's different ways to do
it
attention is a key word you can
have your attention focused or your
breathing an object whatever your mantra
um and and that's very powerful
you can also do it not just with
thoughts with with emotions that's the
favorite meditation exercise of maturity
car it's it's training
um empathy compassion so the brain of
course we now know in neuroscience
is is not fixed you know there's the
whole field of
neuroplasticity it's permanently
changing
and so we can and maybe we should play a
more active role there
i discovered upon reading your book that
it was only until recently ago
that we knew
recently in relative terms
scientists thought that all of the
neurons that you had were present at
birth
and it's only recently that
neuroplasticity and the ability to
change the brain i suppose that before
that
justifying why someone should meditate
if there's not going to be any physical
changes to the brain becomes a much
harder cell
but after that you can say well actually
look we can see what's going on and
that's
you go through um a process of focused
detention meditation that you've done
under your imaging
can you take us through the process of
what happens the focus the distraction
and
and how that sort of manifests
neurologically yeah so
um it it that's exactly the exercise so
you can
compare it somehow to sports right you
can take a weight and and train your
biceps and
you will actually see it's increasing
volume it's a bit
harder to see what's happening in your
in your brain right but these brain
scans
show that the exercise is actually
you um focusing your attention let's say
to your breathing
and then a thought would
come up and and you would observe that
you know you're losing the attention and
you just
bring it back to the object here
uh you're breathing and that circle
of always bringing back attention and
the networks
involved is exactly what we see with
both functional
mri or what you see behind me these
eeg machines measuring electrical
activity of the brain
and so depending on the exercise you do
here training the attention networks
you really see those parts of the brain
actually become thicker
that's what we saw in these buddhist
monks and the connections the pathways
becoming thicker stronger more efficient
and a more connected brain
is a more efficient brain so that was
for me as a scientist
such an eye opener to see with these
objective measures when
people like material and other monks
were in the machines
how they had a very
efficient and direct
control on their thoughts perceptions
emotions and how we could actually see
it
with the machines and that would that's
what we published
isn't it crazy that if somehow the
work that we did internally on our
brains was shown externally
matthew ricard and the dalai lama will
be walking around like professional
bodybuilders
they'd look like these hulking sort of
monsters of muscle and mass
yeah right and so for us of course it's
it's interesting to look at those
extremes now
i'm not a buddhist uh i'm not a monk
uh and and i actually
when um the publisher uh
the book company asked me write a book
about meditation i said well
you know who am i i am um and then
somehow
uh yes i i thought well if i can do it
with my you know as a control freak i'm
such a
nervous personality anyone can do it and
and also i thought
a number of books that i i read uh
somehow for me were quite demanding and
and also
um there's the often the buddhist
angle right and and as my wife says when
when
mature comes he always would stay at
home and she said well it's easy for him
to be
zen you know he's no partner um
no job is she blaming her lack of
mindfulness on you
steven i think that might be a low-key
dig
but i i maybe maybe but but it's true
you know
we have a life very different from these
buddhist monks right so
how do we do it and i think that um
maybe we
sometimes are too demanding
uh you know both um for others and
ourselves and and
so i just wanted to uh propose something
that that is
is um easy to do when you have the
formal
exercises and so it's good to you know
go um
on your uh mat and sit for 10 20 minutes
whatever
um in in in your
meditation uh posture but what do you do
the rest of the day
right so so uh i
figured out that there's many ways to to
do meditation and sometimes we just do
it without explicitly calling it
meditation when you're running when
you're
and and so to me that was um
a very good way actually to to have
uh the the the positive effects
when in my consultation and there's a
lot of things there
dramatic as as we said people losing
their loved one and so on between two
patients families i would just take a
couple of
deep breaths and and maybe the first one
is the most difficult one where you just
refocus you you offer yourself a
pause but you can do that on the train
in in
you know the grocery store when you're
queuing
uh so so
that uh kind of and i'm not a zen master
ask my wife and kids
but but it can really make a difference
to to be in the moment
to observe those thoughts those emotions
and
somehow we create it all in our mind
right and so we
we have all these things going on and
then we lose ourselves in it and
uh you can just train it and and and
i think that's that's good for for my
work as a
as a medical doctor as a
director here of of the lab at the
university which is also very
competitive
um and and within my my relation uh
so that's what i wanted to to share
if i can do it anyone can do it so
that's an interesting
state change right what happens acutely
around the practice of meditation you
get this parasympathetic response
especially if you're combining it with
the breathing so on and so forth
a lot of the people that are listening
will probably be at least familiar with
having tried meditation and maybe to get
into
it um can you walk us through the
effects of long-standing meditation
practices in the brain how's that
characterized what
what happens when you put someone like
matthew ricard or
i guess you haven't had the dalai lama
in but when you get these expert these
experts
is he well if he's listening if he's
listening to tell him to hurry up and he
can stay your he can state yours with
your wife
um but yeah what what's the
characteristic of
of their sort of brain how do they look
so absolutely right chris when you
take a couple of breaths uh you will
just
feel right that there's a direct effect
your
uh heart rate goes down blood pressure
uh your stress hormones if you would
measure them cortisol or adrenaline
and then long-term effects uh and not of
course not only in these monks
studies have shown that if uh you start
doing this after eight weeks
we would see also in in your brain
structural changes so this is a 3d print
of the brain of maturity
he's a little bit with us today
if we measure the gray matter of volume
so
the these billions of brain cells
neurons
those uh specific parts of the
attentional network
um regions like the hippocampus here
deep in in the temporal lobe would
really
show an increase in volume so we can
measure that and we control for
a number of confounding factors um
structures
like prefrontal areas anterior cingulate
cortex so
areas of the brain involved in
attentional control
emotional control they really change um
their volume and their connectivity
because that's the strength of the brain
right these billions of neurons are
talking to each other so that's true the
white matter tracts which is something i
can show you here it's an image
we're not used to see so this is again
the brain of mature but now we look
inside
so these are the thousands of billions
of
connections and we would for example see
the tracts connecting the left and the
right hemisphere
and so if you meditate there's more of
these
big uh highways permitting both parts of
the brain to to uh
work together so that's what we would
really see structural changes
in the brain when you do meditation and
that's reflected in a phenomenological
change in the texture of the mind right
this isn't just like having
bigger muscles it's bigger muscles that
can lift heavier weight
yeah absolutely so so i think um
we can all benefit from this no need of
course to
uh it's it's again like sport you know
you you don't need to run an iron man
already if you go for your jogging on
sundays this is a good thing
probably we don't uh move enough and so
just to have more attention not just for
your physical well-being but also your
mental well-being
i i think is is worth talking about and
and
um for for all of us for myself as a
caregiver it's it's really strange i'm
supposed to take care of others
but somehow i was never thought how to
take care of myself and
um my my job i'm at risk for burnout
i've got two colleagues who committed
suicide we know this for
so long and as you say there's all these
wonderful initiatives on mindfulness
but nothing really structural that is
part of the curriculum and i think
that that can and should change
have you looked at how different volumes
of meditation
track with changes in the brain over
time so have you
looked at somebody say who's done a
thousand sessions 5 000 sessions 10 000
sessions
have you been able to have a look at
that
so uh there's a number of really
good uh labs worldwide
looking at those kinds of longitudinal
effects people like tanya singer in
germany who are really following over
time
cohorts of people who start to meditate
using all these brain scans
and showing that yes practice
makes perfect but it's not about being
perfect it's already about you know
um going through this personal journey
and it's it's
it's a challenge of course for us it's
way easier to show
that one or the other pill right
anxiolytic
or antidepressant or painkiller has an
effect compared to a placebo
um and i would prescribe for everyone
the same
um whatever drug and and um
see the effect here it's it's it's more
of a challenge because
how do you meditate uh there's a lot of
variability there and yet as you just uh
said there are these studies showing the
correlation about
what you're doing and what's happening
in your mind and brain
it's such a shame that our internal
state
is hidden from us right like
as a practice meditator both of us will
be familiar with
finishing a session and not really
knowing if we did well or badly
and then reminding ourselves that having
any sort of judgment about our sit is
negative in any case and i need to
return to the equanimity and
um but it's significantly easier if
you're a power lifter and there's 250
kilos on the floor
you know it's on the floor you know how
heavy it is you know if you've picked it
up it's a very binary can
win or loss game right how many times
did the ball go
in the net how many hoops did you get
the ball through et cetera et cetera
um i think that's that's definitely one
of the challenges or one of the
resistances that people have to
meditation
that it is inherently so
murky to ourselves the success metrics
which everybody gamifies everything now
right how many followers do you have on
instagram you
how many steps did you do today how many
calories did you burn we want
that objective metric of success and um
i'm not a massive fan of muse and other
similar products i've used them for a
very long time and i
i personally for me they they just don't
seem to get at what meditation is
supposed to be about
but yes i appreciate i appreciate that's
the case did you here's another thing
that
i'm intrigued to know have you looked at
the optimal session length
for achieving returns i imagine that
there must be a point at which the
returns in terms of brain change become
to diminish
but i'm familiar with a bunch of
different
meditators who talk about the first 10
to 15 minutes of some sits
essentially be you settling into the sit
itself
there's advocates out there who would
say that yes
get your five minutes in whenever you
can and i agree but
there must also be an optimal amount of
time have you had a look at that
yes but i i think um
it's it's a challenging question right
it depends
why do you meditate okay so what are
your needs
um maybe we should clearly separate if
you have a medical problem if you have
one or the other symptoms that you know
um you can't work properly or function
then
go talk to your medical practitioner and
he will send you if need be to
psychologist or
do uh other tests that that's one thing
the other of course it's
why wait many of my patients say why way
it's a pity
i waited till my you know tension
headache or insomnia or
burnout whatever to discover the the
benefits of meditation so of course we
should
um be more oops uh
doing the the the preventive part and
and
um it's a question i often hear so so
okay
what should i do for how long and people
it's not competition
there's no olympics here uh my
personal take is that really uh you do
what you can
um and you have the formal sessions uh
20 minutes but you know sometimes um
i have five kids so chris sometimes in
the mornings thirty thirty seconds can
feel like a lifetime complete
chaos you take that time
stephen you i don't you know sleep is
also important and all the other things
i don't wanna
so uh that's why i think also informal
meditation and studies have shown that
it also has an impact so um
i think every minute uh you can you can
meditate and the way you actually will
meditate what kind of
exercise you're doing um is
is is good don't don't put the bar
too high don't be as you said this is
this was a bad session or whatever
um so uh
yeah i i'm uh uh
seeing this as a personal journey you
you just try these things out
uh and then depending on the needs of
the moment you will do this or the other
thing a body scan
will for example help my wife fall
asleep it's not my kind of thing and
then
so we all got these these different
exercises then
again maybe this is my personality but
uh sometimes i want to try new things
so so right now i'm in this in this
mantra
uh meditation in the book also there's
david lynch
talking about you know um what he's
doing with transcendental meditation so
um i think we all have different needs
and different you know um
personalities types of how we actually
uh
do this and and it would be strange if
we compare it again with sports that one
would say
you know you you you should go swimming
and
everyone should do swimming yeah
precisely
when i hear that also in the field of
meditation i become a little bit whoa
this is this is strange right so um find
someone who
who and also the way you you mentioned
um
the the wearables and some people like
having these
feedbacks and numbers fine it's there's
great
apps now and and some of my patients
really are
uh happy others hate it and it makes
them nervous uh
so so that i think is the is the
challenge just try it out and then for
yourself
um find out what what is uh
good for you there's an analogy that
someone told me when i was discussing
i'd hit a bit of a wall with my
meditation practice
and i'd been doing shinzen young's five
ways to know yourself
um which is a combination of focus to
mindfulness like
classic mindfulness meditation and um
i've been
i've been doing it for a long time like
maybe three years i think so like
500 sessions or something like that i'd
got in under this one particular
type there's various uh little
iterations within that but it's
essentially the same practice
and he said why would you think that the
boat
which carried you across the river would
get you over land on the other side
and i was like dude that's such a good
analogy that you have particular
practices that work for particular
bits of time areas within your life any
power lifter that's listening anyone
that's ever tried to do weight training
knows you don't stick to the same
exercises from when you start the gym
you cycle through them you periodize the
different things that you do
but again because what is happening
internally within the texture of our own
mind is so murky to ourselves
and there aren't these existing sort of
bodies of knowledge that are quite as
common as we have
in other pursuits like sports and
athletics and stuff like that
it's very difficult to actually learn
these lessons and for someone to say to
me hey man
like why would you think that the boat
that took you across the river would get
you on across land on the other side
that was like a hammer block so i was
like right brilliant so
i'm now part way through kind of
searching for what my
new pursuit will be for a little while
i'm looking at maybe doing zog chen
from your conversation with sam harris
that really sort of opened up
um some curiosity around that i like the
idea of this sort of a non-dual
perspective and then
um what else happened look the sedona
method
which is actually a lot more of a sort
of a cerebral type of an interpersonal
type of meditation that seems
that seems fascinating but yeah it's um
it's an endlessly interesting world to
delve into and the fact that you can do
it at all times within your own mind
is is really really good you looked as
well you talk
in the book about happiness can you
explain
how meditation relates to
phenomenological happiness but on a
neurological level how does that even
work
so again um it's a challenge to define
happiness right and
the pursuit of happiness and um we can't
be
permanently happy right when we had the
first
uh antidepressants prozac and you know
the um
americans taking this to be super happy
which is
it's a challenge that life is not just
always
um a hollywood scenario and then how do
you deal with those
challenges um and
seeing meditation is just something to
make you happy or
just something that can uh reduce stress
or
it it's it's way more than that right uh
but it definitely permits you to maybe
first of all listen to your own emotions
it's a question
that we we often uh ask
a kind of uh polite uh how do you do
how do you do and i'm fine but how do
you really
do how are you it's it's not so easy
um and and that already for me
is because you're i understand also one
of those athletes of the mind and doing
the
higher uh more advanced
courses and and practices but
the people i see in my consultation you
know
sometimes have their
uh you know negative priors
and and and it's just inviting them to
try this out this is not something
magical uh and yes i i do believe
it can make you more happy and
coming back to my favorite guinea pig
material he
journalists call him the the most happy
happiest
man alive yeah which he says it's
ridiculous
uh it's definitely uh not true
and and how could we know that but but
indeed he is
uh kind of showing the opposite brain
pattern as
as people who are depressed and um how's
that characterized
so so well we uh again this uh
prefrontal area here that plays a role
in emotion um control
and how during the different brain scans
uh he his brain and emotional status
reacted
um comes to the conclusion that yes his
happiness circuits but there is no such
thing as a happiness
region or a happiness chemical
right it's it's really networks in a
soup of neurotransmitters
permanently changing again but
yes it permits you
to as you said in the beginning um
react to the reality of what's happening
to us uh
in in in a different way um
and it is interesting to try and
understand
the the neuroscience behind it but i
definitely wouldn't be too arrogant
uh i i i've
uh the past 25 years
with the team trying to understand the
human mind and
sometimes i i hear from colleagues like
you know we've
we've got it all explained and and
nothing is is further from the truth uh
we don't understand how from something
material my favorite organ here and the
brain is definitely important
but we can't explain how from something
an object like this something immaterial
thoughts perceptions emotions arise so
really
i think at one point and also as you
know i had a
christian um education
then went to university very critical
thinking and of course i'm a scientist i
will always confront what i think to
understand with what i think
to measure but when we talk about
consciousness
i don't know can we say we now
made some advance with all these sexy
brain
scans and images can we say we may be
understood 50
of the problem or 5 or 0.005
we just ignore what we ignore and and
talking about our ignorance and just
being a bit um
yeah uh looking at it with more
uh wonder and and and is
is i think good and and kind of the
personal um experience you can even call
it spirituality
i really think that that this is one of
the biggest mysteries and
and um i'm naively optimistic
that we can increase or maybe i should
say reduce our ignorance
give it a try but but it's it's a
challenge and it makes you humble
that is your meditation coming to bear
in your professional world
that is the equanimity that you've
learned to not fixate or suppress the
things that come up during your
meditation
and you're now scaling that across your
research you know this is your life's
work this is what you've dedicated
yourself to
and you're someone now who's manifesting
physically in not just the words that
you say but in the way that you approach
the
the calling that you have in life you're
saying
i'm curious about what is going to
happen but i'm neither fixating nor
suppressing on the results that come
from it i hope that we find more but it
doesn't matter if we don't it's just
naturally
interesting i mean man like if that's
not a beautiful
um explanation for why you can have a
scalable version of meditation that it's
not just the the
state change or the trait change of the
texture of your own mind but actually
the way that you can be
within the world as well i think that's
i think that's awesome you looked at
you looked at free divers as well didn't
you look at some world record freediver
guy that
can dive hundreds of meters on a single
breath what did you learn from them
so guillotine yeah again our
uh area of expertise is the damaged
brain and trying to
improve our care for coma survivors
uh but looking at those other guys those
athletes of the mind not just
the buddhist monks uh but these
um yeah uh world
record holders guillaume neri
is a french
world champion came to the lab
and permitted us to look at how the
brain
works when you're holding your breath in
his case for
seven eight minutes which is really
impressive and he's in an
altered state of consciousness and you
can look at his
movies in youtube he's uh
you know seeing things down there is is
really
um terribly interesting and it reminded
me when i heard him speak
about our study on near-death
experiences actually and sometimes he's
seeing himself
from the outside he's feeling extremely
well
um despite despite being 100 meters
under the water
exactly uh 120 meters
down there and and so yeah we we are
about to publish uh
the workings of his mind and brain
and those other apnea champions so so
it's interesting for us again to learn
from these
extremes we
also have the astronauts so uh
there are now seven up there um
in the international space station and
they uh
are put in the mri scanner in moscow
because not so long ago was only russia
sending them and and then when they come
back uh
from sometimes long periods of zero
gravity it's it's a challenge and we're
preparing to leave this planet go to
mars and so
so again there a wonderful opportunity
for us in the team to study
um another type of athletes the the
astronauts the cosmonauts
so so all of that is very very
interesting um
have you got any predictions uh one
other
very special person is uh
corinne sondran who
is um shaman i
learned a lot from her experiences
when she was in mongolia and and so now
we're comparing well
what is different between those
different exercises of meditation and
hypnosis which is something we
also use in a medical context with uh
cognitive trans germanic trance so
fascinating and how it compares as you
just mentioned
these athletes as guillaume neri were
able to do
extraordinary things before i want to do
um
try and give people an opportunity to
delve into the texture of their own mind
if we've got if we've got time and you'd
be willing to
to give them something interesting maybe
open monitoring or something like that
but before that i had a guy on the show
a few months ago a guy called paul evans
and he is the director of a big events
company out in dubai
and a few years ago probably about 10
years ago
he was put into a medically induced coma
for about three months
he'd had a kidney
a particular type of kidney failure
rapid onset kidney failure due to over
drinking
he was partying a lot and he was put
into a coma for three months
and he wrote a book called when i wake
up
and in this book he explains how
he lived during this coma
in singapore for years
he ran a team of salespeople he could
tell you the color of the tie that he
wore when he went to work the number
plate of the car that he got into
the brand of toothpaste that he used the
different
people who worked for him he got up he
went to work he went home he had a
coffee he had food
and he existed through this four year
period during this time
in his uh altered
world altered universe his dad passed
away
so his dad dies while he's in this
and his family are there around the bed
and apparently
at some point through this they were sat
around the bed and could see
tears streaming down his face but they
didn't know why
and they think or at least paul's
hypothesis
is that this was the period where during
his altered state of consciousness
he was burying his father how
replicable realistic even is this
because this story
sounds so insane and i was sat there
just sort of with my jaw
open listening to him talk is this the
sort of thing that you've encountered in
your work
yes of course for the past 25 years and
those hundreds of people we see
surviving a severe um brain damage
and then often confounded by a
pharmacological coma
where it's very hard for us to know well
when did this actually happen
you know they go through intensive care
and then
the whole time they stay in in the
hospital and then and then rehab
so i somehow
um over time you know
i just try to listen very carefully to
what these people tell us because
uh consciousness
is a subjective first person experience
he is the only one knowing what was
happening
right then and i think historically we
made the error to consider consciousness
as
binary all or nothing and and that's
wrong you can be more or less awake more
or less aware
of what's going on around you of
yourself and
another historical error i think and
we've contributed to
to to showing scientifically uh
how we've been underestimating um
the workings of the mind in case of
severe brain damage it's not
because someone of course can no longer
express uh her or his
thoughts or feelings and people in coma
cannot talk
we have no nonverbal communication
and so we tend to you know um
of course our measure of consciousness
is is making inferences based on the
motor response and it's not because
people
are not responding that in
each and every case nothing is going on
in their brain and mind and
so that became very clear with all the
brain scans
uh so we we should be more careful and
near-death experiences are another
example so anyone listening right now
if you had one of these experiences
please
share them with us uh you will help we
are about 40 people
uh trying to understand kind of email i
know you've got an email address what's
the email address
so for near death experiences it's nde
at liege.be
and anything related to coma it's coma
at
julia.be i think it's it's really
important for us
to just shut up and listen because i
never had one of these experiences and
sometimes i feel like you know the guy
who thinks he knows everything about
color vision
and imagine i would even understand
everything
about what's happening in the brain the
parts of the you know
um brain regions and neurotransmitters
but i myself would be colorblind right
so that theoretical knowledge is
different from the feeling itself
imagine one day i would
see colors something you know would
change and
maybe historically again and this is
going back to descartes
um japan's donkey sui i think therefore
i am
we've been also in the educational
system we were discussing it's all about
you know
thinking and knowing and
what about i perceive therefore i
am and and i think that's maybe the
challenge we're
comparing our brains to computers
it's not a computer and we should invest
more in what makes us
human irrational intuitive
so a challenge there can we do a
practice which can give people a novel
insight into the texture of their own
mind
maybe something that's not just the
breathing if we got something else like
an open monitoring or something like
that anything else you can suggest
so uh whatever classical exercise
indeed would be just to
focus your attention to the breathing we
know that
it's it's a very interesting exercise i
believe
um but you can also kind of
put your spotlight of attention to your
um outside world so i don't know what
you're seeing right now i'm in front of
a window i'm very lucky
so whatever you see if you have a window
well why don't you
just look out of the window and and
maybe
discover that visual
scene in a new way and you can
appreciate the
colors uh i right now see
trees and leaves and and i can
really focus my attention on all those
little
nuances of the the different types of
green and so
um enjoy what is coming through my
senses and be very
aware of the here and now of uh
whatever the visual inputs uh
is there now when you can then play with
other modalities and
um why not now pay attention to what we
hear
um maybe you will
suddenly become aware of the the noise
of your
heating system or
some noises
from outside people talking
animal dog barking whatever and again
you can play with your attention
now maybe bringing it to what you feel
maybe you sit down and what's coming in
again
through these senses and appreciate
kind of your own weight um
different parts of your body or even
your clothing
so suddenly you can focus and appreciate
the awareness of
you know the little pressure of your
clothes
and again do this for the time
you can decide on the different
modalities and appreciate
how you can decide to bring attention
to different parts of your
existence and that's a very simple
exercise
where uh you
uh you can enjoy um
the power of the mind and and
uh experience things a little bit
differently
the fascinating thing that i find about
open monitoring and
walking meditations as well especially
when you really start to tune in
is all of the things which are sensory
inputs
which you do not indulge in noticing
throughout the day
so specifically touch i think is a
really good one touch is almost there
for most of us
really as just an alert system that's
too hot that's too sharp that's to
whatever
so right now i know both me and you are
standing up because we are
21st century desk workers who are
concerned about our posture
but for everybody that's sitting and
listening to this
the sensation of the seat on your body
and the clothes on
you're wearing clothes all day every
single day and yet
do you ever notice the sensation of
clothes on your body despite the fact
that it's covering almost all of your
body
well almost never but you can do that
you can like tuning a radio an
old fm am radio you can allow your
consciousness
to tune itself into that frequency to
get the level of fidelity with which you
are focusing on the sensations that are
coming in
you can tune it to that point where you
can feel the seat beneath you beneath
your legs
or the floor beneath your feet
and then when you can hear the different
sounds maybe you notice there is
something coming in from outside of the
headphones that's
beyond just my voice or maybe you hear
that actually i haven't cleaned up the
audio of this
this track particularly well and there's
a tiny little bit of buzz in the
background and i wonder what that is
and that's just understanding that
simply in the most
mundane experiences
there is essentially a bottomless pit
that you can dig into i think that
that's why meditation is interesting to
me
and the deeper that you can get access
to that experience i think the richer
and richer your life is
absolutely and so uh that's actually
uh what we've been studying for the past
decade so you have these
awareness networks we we just mentioned
external awareness
internal awareness these are two
networks emotional networks
so these are the exercises you can just
focus your attention
uh observe and that that's really very
very powerful and and you can do it in a
very formal way
but you can also just when you go
running um
for you know
doesn't need to be your whole run but
just
decide okay now i'm paying attention to
my feet
hitting the ground and i can really
appreciate and you can really break it
down
or now i'm focusing my attention to what
i'm
seeing during the run and so and then
sometimes you just let it go and
have your mind thinking about anything
so it's
that's the exercise just
playing with these things you can do the
guided meditation if you like it with
the apps and then you can do it yourself
without any help uh doing it alone
doing it you know with your partner or
with a bunch of people
so that's quite uh individual again and
and the challenge is to find
what fits you best at this specific
moment in time
very much so for people who might be
thinking i wonder where to get started
i would highly recommend headspace is
fantastic
calm is fantastic sam harris's waking up
app is also really really good
if you google five ways to know yourself
by shinzon young it is free
and it is the most comprehensive
explanation of how the different areas
of mindfulness meditation come together
from sort of a practical perspective
also the no-nonsense meditation book
a scientist's guide to the power of
meditation by mr stephen laurie's md
will be linked in the show notes below
on amazon of course
um where else should people go if they
want to keep up with the fascinating
research that you do
where else can people head so there's uh
a lot of opportunities as you just
mentioned
uh something i prescribed than in my
outpatient clinic is mindfulness-based
stress reduction so you have these
eight-week programs and i know you're in
good hands you have someone
who's been trained and the science has
actually
shown that uh the different exercises
you see there
uh can be beneficial and will lead to
these
uh changes in in brain structure people
can go on retreats
so so it's it's really this this journey
there's
in the book a number of websites uh for
those who
uh who like it you mentioned already the
wearables the apps on the internet
there's
uh really so many ways your podcast
uh to find your own uh your own way so
uh i think the only thing you need
uh to start meditating is
your own curiosity and motivation
and if that is there you know you can
start your journey
and i wish you a very
pleasant one i love it i'm gonna finish
it with the quote that you actually
begin the book with which you say
you don't have to control your thoughts
you just have to stop them
stop letting them control you
exactly but we can talk about it
and read about it the challenge is now
really to
experience it because you know it's
happening between your ears
nobody can meditate for you so that's
that's the invitation
uh for me was a discovery i i really
enjoyed how from a skeptic
actually uh i heard only negative things
about meditation during my training in
medical school and
later in neurology and now you know
we're having this this discussion
and and the research going on really
showing and there's hundreds of
scientific papers every year
that there is added value so hopefully
more people will be able to try it out
if we haven't convinced them today then
i'm going to give up stephen thank you
very much for coming on i really
appreciate it
thank you so much thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace